يخبرك الطريق إلى كوباني عن مدى وحشية
هذا الجدار بالفعل وإلى أين
يتجه هنا
، قُتلت الناشطة الكردية هاردمان حلوف برصاص المتمردين السوريين الذين
دعموا تركيا مقطع فيديو مروعًا
لقتل الفيروس المنتشر على الإنترنت
خارج نيسا مباشرةً ، وهو
معسكر ضخم لعائلة داعش هناك  الذعر
وإطلاق النار أمام
الشاحنات تستدير للعائلات السريعة التي
يأتون إليها وهم يغادرون مباشرة
على الطريق تنسحب هذه الدورية - حسنًا
إنهم لا يريدون التحدث إلينا ولكن من
الواضح أن الأمريكيين ما زالوا ينشطون في مناطق
حول الأكراد السوريين لأنهم  ترك
تركيا يجعل طموحها الجريء أن أذهب إلى
أي مكان هنا
[موسيقى]
لكن بقدوم اثنين منا  مروحيات أباتشي
تدور حول المنطقة
وتظهر دوريتهم أن الأمريكيين ليسوا مستعدين
للقيام بذلك حتى الآن على الرغم
من غرائز الرئيس ترامب لإنهاء الحروب التي لا نهاية
لها لأنه يقول الحرب الجادة على الرغم من أنها
تستمر في الحصول على وقت أطول عندما
أخبرني مسؤول أمريكي وفي الواقع في  الطريق الآن
باتجاه بارني حيث
تم قطع بعض قواتهم من
قبل المتمردين السوريين المدعومين من تركيا ، فأقمت
نقاط تفتيش خارج تلك المدينة
[موسيقى]
، وبينما نبتعد ، يبدو من الواضح أن
تركيا تخطط للاستيلاء على الطريق
جزئيًا  ناقلات الجنود
المدرعة والدبابات التركية التي تحمل الأعلام التركية
يصل المزيد منها في الغبار
قريباً لن يتمكن الأكراد السوريون من
النزول إلى هنا على الإطلاق وغرب
منطقتهم معزول عن
شرقها وترك مدينة كوباني مرة أخرى لمواجهة  حصار نيك
باتون والش CNN I Nisa شمال شرق
سوريا